[Music]
the wyman family kate charlie and their
daughter Shila love to shop at the
stuart department store kate receives a
message on her store app inviting her to
preview the season's latest fashion kate
forwards the invitation deshyla and then
uses the app to book an appointment with
her personal stylist shila's sees some
clothes she likes and pins them on
pinterest so her friends can comment
charlie often shops from home on the
store's website today
he needs a device on power tools as he's
planning to build a bookshelf
he reads articles and reviews which lead
him directly to the tools he needs kate
visits the store after a tough day at
work the app recognizes Kate and a
holographic salesperson greets her by
name and invites her to interact with a
touchscreen that shows all her personal
preferences in recent searches the app
also alerts Kate's stylist of her
arrival Kate finds a dress she loves but
unfortunately her size isn't available
her stylist checks the stock management
system and finds the dress in her size
at a partner store if Kate wants the
dress it can be delivered wherever she
wishes kate decides to buy it as she
checks out the cashier uses facial
scanning technology to sense Kate's mood
the cashier can tell that kate has had a
rough day so she gives her a courtesy
discount that helps brighten her day
this is a typical shopping experience in
today's API enabled digital economy
leading companies are already using AP
is to innovate customer experiences to
tap new opportunities generate new
revenue channels by exploring new
partner ecosystem connect app data
location sensing and empathy Maps to
improve customer experiences with their
brand IBM can give you the competitive
edge to win in the digital era to help
you connect anything to everything
because when everything is connected
anything is possible connecting lives
creating experiences
[Music]